[Applause]
i think we need to pack the cords
i'm wet by them bro i'm big biden kamala
we need to pack the courts and we need a
young puerto rican black man on those
courts i imagine they attack the courts
with alex media
dude that would be hilarious the supreme
court justice alex media
that'd be so [ __ ] lit it would be
amazing
let's go every [ __ ] decision has a
giant decision by alex
i think a lot of other people
contributed this decision by one person
i like that that's perfect oh my god
i said you gotta run for president so if
i run for president
president permanent yeah i run for
president yep
i can nominate anybody i want to the
supreme court
but they have to be confirmed by the
senate um how are we going to get the
senate to confirm you
we run for senate yeah we got overall
majority in the senate we got that
yeah taylor easy as that you've got a
government i'm sorry
i'm really bad at government so i don't
know
which one's highest you think the
government is good at government come on
yo
i don't know the requirements needed for
like supreme enough requirements
alex aoc was a bartender you got that
you got a thinkpad
heavies she had
[Music]
do you think that's an advantage for a
congresswoman
what to have the heavies yes
they have the back breaker you never had
that
the spot the spinal
spinal bifida
she's popping out with the biffs come on
bro
oh my god dude that's an advantage
it's so true yeah we call one the house
calling the senate that's all you need
yeah so wait what's the problem with her
being a bartender
there's no problem with this she just
had them [ __ ] heavy she had that
[ __ ] she did what's wrong with it
you're saying there's something wrong
with it no i'm not yes you did you said
that a congresswoman shouldn't have them
lunchable
[Laughter]
you said that you were judging we're out
here just trying to say there's nothing
wrong with it
you know what i mean if she got that
crook back from them cats
there's nothing wrong with it yeah she's
a hunchback of the bronx
that's what they call it she's the
punchback of notre bronx
the hunchback is
let's go [ __ ] out here jeff bezos yeah
that's all it was she's just jealous his
base was his head looks like one of her
biggest
yo far too many people this way that
[ __ ] is perfect
real tough yeah i want aoc to run for
president uh-huh i want to
run anywhere
in slow motion
[Laughter]
but is that crazy that half a million
people listen to this podcast and we're
talking like this
i think we don't realize how popular
this podcast is what do you mean
like it's crazy like aoc's like um
i think she's listening she might be
listening bro yo
alexandria yo hey ayo what's up baby hey
afc what's up
we got we got we got supreme court
justice alex media right here
with the gavel
[Laughter]
in the
hour
geez you're getting me all wet with your
motorboat
oh it's too crazy hey if you're driving
in that motorboat aoc got a couple
floatation devices
we don't need we don't need a piano jack
we got the heavies that's why leonardo
dicaprio died in time today because she
ain't have the
candy
yo why was that [ __ ] on the couch on
her side
but she couldn't get in her side when
she was on the door
oh selfish ass right like when he was
down there
you don't think he was looking at her
like remember when i was
drawing you [ __ ] and you're on your
side you couldn't do that
yeah hey right here look and then we
both live twice as much room
exactly we've been looking at each other
like that simple as that
it was mad selfish it was selfish no
titty having
aoc
shout out to aoc bro is she in the
senate or
is she married say what is she married
she probably got a white guy
yeah she does part of the lgbt
community because she got a white man
she got away man why do you think she's
part of the lgbt movie
maybe she's like puss you think she
liked that poon in it
you think she really liked that poon in
it
do you think she does or what i don't
think she's
not never tried it but do you think if
she tries she might like that
pin in it bro you are about to be so
tight dude talk to me dogs you want to
see
you want to see her man super simp
riley roberts
[Music]
looking like a proud boy bro
looks like he's about to kidnap the
governor for [ __ ] michigan
oh my god can you bring that super
simple up onto the picture right there
[Music]
oh [ __ ] knock off angela [ __ ]
prince harry
oh my what's that name angela prince
harry what's the girl angela robert
meghan markle yeah meghan markle oh my
god
i [ __ ] get angela i don't know i
blacked out he's thinking uh power
i think i guarantee you he wasn't
thinking of power i thought it was a lot
of all the things mom was thinking about
mark's watching power there's a
different kind of power i can believe
he's interested in yeah i was only
wikipedia
i was thinking of empire i think all
right hold on can we go back to this
guy see he kind of looks like he's crazy
seth rogen's
his husband he looks like ginger rogan a
little bit
like the middle pitcher that ginger set
an aoc
i cannot believe that you were like a
swagless edge hearing
yeah yeah yes if ed sheeran had no swag
no musical
no but you know i mean he might be heavy
dicks you don't know
i don't know you don't think he got the
big one you got the low rise
you got the
yes you know what the deal was yo do you
think can you go to another picture
orange two then say what is this pubic
hair irons too
usually is that what happens i think i
don't know yeah
i think sometimes fire crotch you know
where that comes from yeah i mean
go to my man's on the right okay wow
come on bro he might listen to the
podcast no disrespect if you listen to
the podcast
can you get the picture when he's in a
blue shirt it's bottom right
that one right there oh that's that's
not
i don't know dogs i don't know bro
looking crazy she she could do better
she looks like she
gets dating him in that picture she's
like what am i doing i got to see him
walk
watch because you could tell a big dick
i believe this from taylor
you could tell or august would you like
you